GUEST SPEAKER:
Morning, governor.
As you're well aware, how
best to prevent or compensate
for wetland destruction is a
crucial and contentious debate
here in Oregon at the moment.
However, a local watershed
advocacy group currently
recommends new methodology
for calculating
the value of these wetlands.
I'm eager to share
what I see are the pros
and cons to this method.
First of all, I'll
explain a little bit
about how it compares
to our current tactics
that we're using.
Then I'll discuss
some major critiques.
And then I'll conclude and
wrap up with my thoughts
and recommendations.
So the current system
we have right now,
we require three
acres of wetlands
to be created for every
acre that's destroyed.
People have complained that
this really hinders development
and that there's little
room for creating
these new wetlands right now.
Landowners,
particularly farmers,
have started a system
of mitigation banking,
where they turn acres of
their land into wetlands
and then sell these
acres to developers
who use it as
compensatory wetlands,
or essentially wetlands credit.
The main problem
with this system
is that it's unclear whether
these new wetlands are really
functioning how they should be.
Wetlands execute a number
of ecosystem services
like water storage, carbon
sequestration, water
filtration, services
that are particularly
beneficial for humans as well.
So it'd be a better approach
to look specifically
at these services to recognize
what we would have to replace.
So this new system
would require adding up
the total value of what these
ecosystems' services are
worth to humans
in monetary terms.
As they aren't currently
bought and sold on the market,
this evaluation process
can be challenging.
But a mixture of different
processes can be used.
We can use market
goods as a proxy.
For example, flood barriers can
cost up to around $15 billion,
while coral reefs do
this naturally for free.
So it provides a comparison.
We can look at
revealed preferences,
like seeing people, if
they travel to x place
to see nature, it gives
a sense of their value,
but also using
hypothetical markets
like measuring people's
willingness to pay.
Using this process, Robert
Costanza and his team
calculated that
ecosystem services
are worth $142.7 trillion
annually in 2014 US dollars,
which is a profound
number to really show
how these ecosystems, or
services are of value.
Of course, there are many
critiques and arguments
for why this is not a
really applicable process.
Critiques specifically to
the framework of method,
first of all, include that
the economic assumptions
are usually inappropriate.
It assumes everyone
is always trying
to maximize a personal
utility function
and assumes that goods
are substitutable,
which is not always the case.
Also, there's an issue
with discounting.
It's problematic to assume
that ecosystems in the future
have diminished value.
People also identify that
people's ability to evaluate
is flawed.
People don't necessarily have
a complete understanding,
like what a particular
soil microorganism will do.
People are also asked
to put a price on things
that aren't normally
priced, and so it
makes it a challenge to judge.
Essentially, valuation
methods and market schemes
are not ideologically neutral.
It's said they're
culturally construed,
so therefore, there's a risk
of having high subjectivity.
Zooming out in terms of these
critiques, the quantification
of nature, people will say, in
the first place is problematic.
Valuing nature is arguably
a personal and social value
at the level of morals.
And so therefore,
no amount of money
can be effectively compared.
Others will also argue
that commodification
induces competition, which
can be counterproductive.
It basically undermines
the moral incentives
of conservation by making it
about self-interest instead.
Despite these critiques and
these arguments against it,
I would still recommend it,
though, as a valuable exercise.
Although the process itself
clearly has some flaws,
by spelling out all the
different assumptions
we make, we can perhaps not
reduce the subjectivity,
but can at least be
transparent about the thinking
that we're implying.
Also in terms of the
moral implications,
currently with the
system that we have,
we're already using markets
for ecosystem services
with the mitigation
banking procedure.
The Army Corps of Engineers
has cut the cost $45,000
to replace a acre of wetland.
So in a way, we're already
quantifying these wetlands.
Instead, we would just
be valuing the services
that they provide.
Furthermore, I'd argue that we
should focus on the outcomes
regardless of the different,
differing ethical philosophies.
Economic arguments tend
to be more salient.
They fit with the ideological
and institutional structures
in place, and thus have
shown remarkable success
in political recognition
and spurring policy
around ecosystem conservation.
Currently, without valuing
ecosystems in this way,
in formal policy evaluations
like cost-benefit analysis,
we are effectively assigning
them a value of zero.
So instead, by illustrating
the immense value to humans,
the critical need to
preserve these services
becomes much more salient both
land owners and developers.
Although Marc Sagoff
shows how the back story
or political rationale
has been misportrayed,
the parable of
how New York chose
to restore the
Catskills Watersheds
illustrates this value.
Restoring, restoration
cost them $1 billion,
whereas a new filtration
plant, on the other hand,
cost up to $6 billion, which
shows the great efficiency
in natural ecosystem services.
The greater lesson,
however, indicates
that we should be seeking to
preserve rather than always
restore.
This can save ourself
money in the long run.
As this methodology
makes this message clear,
I see great utility in using
an ecosystem services approach.
Although money is not
the end-all be-all
and shouldn't be,
putting it in these terms
creates great political
agency for conserving
the ecosystems depend on.